technical issues according to the sign
posted kept people from using the main
entrance to an office tower in moscow's
central business district the issue a
drone strike it's the second drone
strike on this Russian government
building this week
first hit was early Sunday Ukraine has
not taken responsibility and it's not
clear why this particular building is
being targeted
this Russian man likened the hit to a
mosquito biting a human but he also says
nowhere is 100 percent safe in Russia
now Russians had been previously
insulated from the Kremlin so-called
special military operation in Ukraine
until early May that's when the Kremlin
was hit
this man says he's from Donetsk and
dismisses the attacks in Moscow saying
they're nothing compared to the Daily
shelling and deaths in his Ukrainian
hometown
officials in her son shared video from
inside a hospital hit just after 11 A.M
broken glass and blood stains the
Hallmarks of another deadly strike the
World Health Organization noted in May
that it verified more than one thousand
attacks on health care facilities in
Ukraine since the start of the full
invasion the most it has ever recorded
in any humanitarian emergency here a
young doctor was killed and a nurse
among the wounded
it was his first day at work after an
internship says the head of the hersan
regional Administration Medical
Department
is being accused of terrorist attacks by
Russia's defense spokesperson the claim
is that Ukraine targeted Russian
civilian boats in the Black Sea with
unmanned attack vessels Russia says it
destroyed them Ukraine denies attacking
civilian boats
Crystal gemancing Global News London